[Music]
and if you want pressure then i send my
dogs you know the little [ __ ] gonna
eat
told them for beginning my [ __ ] we win
and we never gonna take no defeat
free all my young [ __ ] out in the
field i pray they do better for real
and i know some [ __ ] it's dying to
kill they don't give a [ __ ] how you feel
i'm never gonna sign no deal unless the
[ __ ] come with a meal
i'm coming with a whole lot of skill and
[ __ ] that's not for real
hey you love [ __ ] better do better
ain't nothing but money they sit on my
schedule
la mama she with it she waited i
promised lashawna do whatever i tell her
i'll take off on the propeller if you
want smokey that [ __ ] whatever oh no
y'all [ __ ] said i wouldn't get it that
bad guy
they gonna let me forever oh i'll catch
a plane like belka oh
my
[Music]
[Music]
dab and they kept down and i was giving
them glasses they didn't believe i'd
make it out rapping
yeah it's pit heavy [ __ ] better know
that [ __ ]
he's still on his own seats then when
i'm from little [ __ ]
mama skewed my language
[ __ ]